-Hi, Sandra, how are you?
-I'm great, Seth.
I'm so happy to talk to you.
-I'm so happy
to talk to you, as well.
And we have something
in common right now.
I've been doing the show
from my in-laws' house,
and you are also in
someone else's home right now.
-Yes, I am quarantining
in Vancouver
because when you come to Canada,
you have to quarantine
for two weeks,
and it just so happens
that my sister and her famil
are on vacation
for exactly these two weeks,
so I'm in her
wonderful home, yeah.
-And is there anything
about her home
you would change,
or do you feel
like it absolutely aligns
with your taste?
-[ Laughs ]
One, I love her home so much
'cause there are
so many things to do here.
I'm always fantasizing of, like,
redoing my sister's house,
and she gets angry
with me for it.
But it's just like --
You know what I mean?
Like, during a Zoom
when you meet people,
you know, a lot of times
these things are
super-curated behind you.
You're always wanting
to see how people live.
-Sure.
-And the thing in this house
like, with my nieces
and all their artwork
and the stuff that they do
is it's just so real.
Like, this is like
how families live
with, like, a lot of stuff
and a lot of games and --
And there's no kind of curation,
but I just felt like
what I wanted to show you
was that there's
this one particular room.
Like...
I did not touch it.
And I was like,
"I think I really want
to show Seth this room
because the amount of activities
that are possible in this room."
So can I show you the room
-Please.
Oh, my God. This is great.
-Yeah, and it's also because
they're vacationing,
like, basically
in the middle of the ocean
[Laughing] They're totally
not going to watch this.
-We'll make sure
not to put it online,
so if they don't see it
as it airs...
Oh, my God.
What's going on behind you
Is that for a cat?
-Here first, my nieces
are very good artists, so --
Again, I didn't
touch anything, man.
This is just how it is.
-[ Laughs ]
-Here we have
wonderful art supplies.
-Yeah.
-And I hear this
is called a cat tree?
-Yep, yep.
-Got this cat tree.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is a very low couch.
-Uh-huh.
-Oh. Here's a neck pillow.
There's a neck pillow here
-That's great.
Oh, my God. Is that
a ping-pong table?!
Am I seeing the corner
of a ping-pong table?
-This is a ping-pong table
in the middle of the room.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is the greatest reveal.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-I don't think any of us
could have sketched
the unseen part of this room
from the little piece
we saw in the beginning.
What have you got over there
-Can you see this?
-Yeah. We can see.
-Then the girls will play piano.
-Okay. Wow!
[ Piano plays ]
So one plays piano, and th
other one's playing ping-pong.
-This is a bongo drum.
Again, I did not --
I did not place any of this.
There's just, like, a bongo drum
in the corner of this room
-I mean, I think this speaks
to the level of actor you ar
that you're just
doing interviews
while you know
that's all just a room away.
And we can't read it
on your face at all.
We're just led to believe
you're in a normal, simple room.
-Well, a simple room
in a real house, you know?
-Yeah.
-That's also --
Also, of course,
I take inspiration
from your background.
-Thanks. Well, this is --
It's amazing how --
how little love
I had for knickknacks
until I had to do a show
by myself.
And all of a sudden,
every single thing I saw
was just endless opportunity
-I know. Like -- Like this
-See? Exactly.
Somebody saw that and said
"I want that in my house."
-Yeah. Yeah. Actually I thin
one of the girls made it.
-Oh, well, then I take it back
Gosh, that sounds awful.
I mean, if my child made that,
I'd be so proud.
But if someone else's child made
it and tried to sell it to me,
I probably wouldn't buy it
-Probably not. No.
-Hey, congratulations
on the Emmy nominations
for "Killing Eve."
I imagine one of the most
exciting things is the fact --
Because, again, it's such
an exceptionally well-writte
show with two female leads
And the fact that you both
get nominated
must just be such a perfec
conclusion to each season.
-Oh, it's amazing.
And then I'll also add
Fiona Shaw.
-Who's so good.
So it's like all the women
in the show have been nominated,
and it's just extraordinary.
And it also speaks to, like --
You know, I just want to offer
a moment of hope
and like, yay, and a win.
You know what I mean?
Like, you know, three season
into the show, you know,
that is primarily
about this relationship
between Villanelle and Eve
we also have Carolyn,
played by Fiona Shaw,
who is also rewarded
with recognition.
It's great. It's so great.
It's just this year, you know,
because I'm not exactly sure
what's going to go on
with the Emmys,
and they will probably
be in England, you know,
at I don't know what time
in the morning, right?
That's the one thing that I wish
that I could be there with them,
that we could all be together.
-First of all, let me say I have
so much respect for you no
because you have both been
a nominee and a host.
And so I feel like
you understand
the great pressures of hosting
these awards shows, as well.
When you were sitting
in the audience as a nominee
have you been able
to enjoy those evenings?
Or are you nervous?
Are you -- Do you have anxiety
-First off,
before I answer that,
I just want to say
that I'm a big fan
of your writing staff.
-They're really good.
-Yes, because I'm sure --
I'm not the only one.
Because I actually met them.
Because they wrote for me
when I hosted the Golden Globes.
So all that experience
is also for me wrapped up
in a lot of your writing staff
And that is a big difference
It's like, you know --
The level of nervousness
is totally different.
I will never do that again
I will never host again.
It's so -- It was crazy.
It was so crazy.
I've never been so nervous
or frightened in my life.
Actually frightened.
But as a nominee, it all kind of
depends on, like, the placement.
I will say, having been
a nominee before, for "Grey's,
usually, like,
Supporting comes early.
-Yeah.
-You are only nervous
for a certain amount of time
and then you can let go.
You know what I mean?
You win or you lose.
You just kind of --
then kind of chill out.
But there's always
this low-grade level
of -- of anxiety or energy
And it doesn't even matter
what you feel about it.
-It's true.
-It's just --
You can't really eat.
Going to the bathroom badly.
You know what I mean?
-It's really funny
how all the justification
you can do leading
up to it about,
you know, it's an honor
to be nominated
or awards don't matter,
the work's what matters.
Like, as it gets closer,
your body just is like --
"Don't tell us about that.
We're so excited!"
-And you know the thing that -
-It's really fun, though.
-I think the thing that is
actually the most calming --
and I'm sure that you've
experienced this, as well.
It is an amazing opportunity
and rare
that you get to see
a bunch of people,
you know, basically
fellow nominees and actors
One, you get to meet
actors and artists
who you might not know
that you could have
an opportunity to say hi to.
And then also for people
who you kind of know
and only kind of see
in these certain situations.
It's like -- Laura Linney.
I just love her so much.
She's also a nominee
in my category.
I haven't seen her
in a long time.
And then
we're in the same category
And it was so good
to kind of see her again.
That's also a --
I wonder how it's going to be,
you know,
this year at the Emmys,
how to kind of
reach out to people.